my name is Tamara chambers and I'm about
to watch Return to Oz for the first time
ever could be so much fun Oh cameras
never seen it's like this horrifying
combination of like Twilight Zone in The
Waltons
first of all they show Dorothy who is
apparently aging in Reverse because she
looks like she's 7 years old she's
incredible hair though so Dorothy finds
a key on her farm in Kansas that says
oszi and she looks at it for a hundred
years then she takes the key and runs to
Aunt Em because of course and M already
thinks she's crazy
so Aunt Em takes her to a doctor who is
going to use electrical currents to cure
her of her belief in Oz which is
actually pretty progressive for the time
so way to go and there's a doctor and a
nurse mrs. Wilson who's super horrifying
and like real fierce and then it just
magically turns into a horror film
right in front of your eyes Return to Oz
the story about Dorothy Gale in Kansas
turns into a horror film
so Dorothy's in this sight board
basically strapped down to this chair
about to get electrocuted for believing
in Oz and and there's this terrifying
nurse in this amazing black dress and
this doctor and they're about to
electrocute her and then a lightning
storm happens and the whole place goes
black so the nurse and the doctor leave
Dorothy to go take care of some other
patients who are moaning
scarily and creepily
so then they escaped through this dark
forest well mrs. Wilson is chasing them
and her amazing dress it's amazing it's
really because and they fall into a
river and all of a sudden out of nowhere
there's like a floating piece of wood
like in the Titanic just chill in there
just and then it turns into like a crib
that's floating which it turns into it's
like chicken coop identically it looks
like a crib and it's floating in the
middle of a river and then that river
turns into like the fucking ocean so
they're just out in the middle of
nowhere in an ocean in a crib that's
floating then Dorothy wakes up and
there's a talking chicken in the crib
which it's chicken times every sysm of
gopis of course it is the ocean is dried
up and it's just pond and they're in Oz
bah bah bah
the chicken is named ballina which is
her chicken from the farm okay
but honestly she's super funny she's the
best part of the movie I really think 10
out of 10 would recommend watching
Billina again she's way better than all
of the other famous chickens so they go
across the little chunk of the evil
desert and you find out that the bad
guys are rocks it's actually pretty then
they get to a tent city or what is left
of Emerald City and these things show up
the wheelers
what what look they're like loud playboy
at slenderman's on rollerskates it's
amazing it's so scary because first of
all they have gotten so much bleep then
the faces on it and you're like what the
fuck is that
is that a claymation and then they put
their faces up and it's they're humans
but they're on rollerskates and they
look like slender men but very very
flamboyant and giggly so after a while
that wheelers were feel that the Nome
King is the evil big bad guy and that he
doesn't allow chickens chickens aren't
allowed in Oz so then Dorothy valina the
best chicken in the world and their new
friend tick-tock go to princess mombi's
house to retrieve the Scarecrow who is
now the leader of the Emerald City
that's now destroyed and honestly the
best part of that scene is when Molina
sees the house for the first time and
goes wow this princess mombi is some
house cleaner it's like girl hew live in
a chicken coop with poop way to stay
humble though then princess mombi locks
Dorothy up in the tower in the hopes
that in a couple years her head will
ripen for her head collection so that
she can shop northey's head off and use
it for herself because she's a headless
horrifying
but this is for kids so in the tower
Dorothy meets Jack which is like a
pumpkins like Jack Skellington this is
like work hard to meet than the actual
cartoon of Jack Skellington um she means
Jack and Jack keeps calling her mom
which is weird
Dorothy Jack and the most wonderful
chicken in the world make the plan to
escape by creating this character made
out of a Gump which is like like a deer
and they put his head on top of a sofa
with some plants to flap away it doesn't
hold up with science it's not scientific
at all I will not give them that but
they need this powder from the princess
and so she doesn't steals the powder and
then all of her heads catch her and so
all of our heads are screaming and then
the headless princess mombi is chasing
them and it's so fucking scary
it's like horrific like it's like horror
film scary and this is for kids which is
awesome I love it I can't imagine
watching this as a child I kept in
fetching my mom didn't let me watch
Rugrats
no it's good it scared the shit out of
me but anyways they get the powder and
they're sprinkling it on this gump
character and she flies away as the
headless mombi is chasing men so they're
escaping through the air on this
nightmare machine of this like Gump head
and the sofa in some plants and
meanwhile he's like what am i is he's
flapping through the air and they're
like you're a thing is your thing
literally what she says she's like well
you're a thing also Jack keeps calling
Dorothy's mother and I know the jack is
a newborn pumpkin man but it seems like
he's a full-grown pumpkin man
she's man-shaped and it's creepy so as a
flying for the air the wheelers come
looking for them again and on second
inspection
I love the wheelers they are super cool
and I want to try on their skates then
Dorothy all of them crash in the Gump
the disassembles and is everywhere and
they're on Nome mountain so this is the
first time you see the Nome King and he
sounds like Mufasa and kylo Ren put
together and he looks like an evil clump
of play-doh and it's awesome so the Nome
King transfers them down to his
underground secret rock lair where he
reveals that he has the ruby slippers in
the best way it's like this incredible
reveal like they're very powerful
so the Nome King makes them play this
game where they have to guess which
knickknacks are their friends she's
pretty messed up and a fucking course on
the last try Dorothy gets it then you
see the Scarecrow and he is
horrifying-looking it kind of not been
good to him like I know it's only been
six months but like maybe he has a
drinking problem
then at they're trying to escape all of
the evil Plato rocks attack them and
right as the evil Nome King is about to
eat Jack they pretend Jack Skellington
character one of the Linda's eggs that
pops into his mouth and destroys
everything done they like melts like the
witch like the evil witch Lincoln that's
all it took one egg girl works good
under pressure so Dorothy has two
slippers back and everything's restored
and she sees the Scarecrow and the lion
and the Tin Man and they all look bad
and weird and I love it so Dorothy
leaves Oz with the promise from the
queen of Oz that she can return any
time she likes and she leaves her
chicken friend which is a bitch Moo
honestly then she's like magically back
on the Riverside in Kansas where she
like fell overboard at the hospital and
total fines her like a champion and
that's right when I realized that Toto
had not been in the movie at all like he
didn't go back to Oz he's like bark bark
fuck that she'd bark hi have fun I like
lions
so who's then you see that mrs. Wilson
was always princess mombi moby moby dick
and she's arrested and ends up in a cage
just like princess mombi did mmm and
it's just all so fucked up like it's so
weird and cool and horrifying and creepy
and like you can tell a lot of money was
put into it
but it also looks real janky in the best
way like it's stuck to the weird themes
of the old movie but did justice to the
books more so because of the ultra
weirdness that it brought into it and it
was so uncomfortable to watch like if
you puts the through eight and how did
they catch this girl it was a weird
choice I feel like the girl is weird
Joyce the weird puppet characters were
awesome I love that they kept like you
had some kind of idea what was happening
because of Wizard of Oz but if you've
never in the books you're like what's
going on they're like oh yeah it's troll
mountain or no mountain I don't know
it's one of those it's it's no mountain
and like now like all I want is a horror
series for were not for and like now
like all I want is a horror series based
on return to us I just continues the
story as like a weekly like American
Horror Story but like just weird puppets
and little girls who should be older
than they are but it's like they're
Benjamin
you know come on HP oh I just cannot
imagine watching this as a child are you
kidding me Wheeler's no what the fuck
haven't you watch this is a kid how did
you do that oh my god is that why the
Walker brothers are so weird make sense